let's try to learn a thing or two about
ratios
so ratios are just expressions that
compare quantities so that might just be
a fancy way let me just of saying
something that you may or may not
understand so let me give you actual
examples if i have 10 horses
10 horses and i have
5 dogs
and someone were to come to me and say
sal what is the ratio
what is the ratio of
horses
of horses
to dogs
so i want to know how many horses do i
have for some number of dogs so i could
say i have 10 horses
i have 10 horses for every
five dogs so i could say the ratio of
horses to dogs is 10
to
5.
or i could also write that as a fraction
i could say the ratio of horses to dogs
is 10
to
or i could just write it out i could say
it is
ten
two five these all are saying the same
thing and the thing i write first or the
thing that i write on top is the number
of horses
so this is the number of horses right
there that's the number of horses and
that's all the number of horses
if i want to talk about the number of
dogs this is the number of dogs that's
the number of dogs or that's the number
of dogs i'm just these are all just
expressions that are comparing two
quantities now i just said i have ten
horses for every five dogs but that what
does that mean that means i have
five horses for every one dog
sorry not five horses for every one dog
that means i have two horses for every
one dog right if for five dogs i have
ten that means for every one of these
dogs there are two horses for every one
of these dogs there are two horses for
every one of every two of these horses
there's one dog and i just kind of
reasoned through that so this is
i have two horses for every
one dog but how do you get there how do
you get from
ten to five to two to one well you can
think of what's the biggest number that
divides into both of these numbers
what's their greatest common divisor i
have a whole video on that but the
biggest number that divides into both of
these guys is five so you divide both of
them by five and you can kind of get
this ratio into a reduced form
and if i write it here it would be the
same thing as 2 to 1 or
or
2 2 1. and so what's interesting about
ratios it isn't literally or doesn't
always have to be literally the number
of horses and the numbers of dogs you
have what a ratio tells you is how many
horses do i have for every dog or how
many dog do how many dogs do i have for
every horse now just to make things
clear what if someone asked me what is
the ratio
of
of dogs
to horses
dogs to horses so what's the difference
in these two statements
here i said horses to dogs here i'm
saying dogs to horses
dogs to horses
so since i've switched the ratio
what i'm looking for i'm looking for the
ratio of dogs horses i switched the
numbers so dogs for every five dogs i
have ten horses or if i divide both of
these by five for every one dog i have
five horses so the ratio of dogs to
horses is five to ten or one to five or
you could write it this way 1 to i could
write it let me write it down here
1 to 5 or i could write 1 2 5. and the
general convention this wouldn't be
necessarily incorrect that's not wrong
but the general convention is to get
your ratio or your fraction if you want
to call it that into the simplest form
or into this reduced form right there so
let's just do a couple of other examples
let's say i have let's say i have
apples
i have 20 apples let's say i have
oranges
40 oranges and let's say that i have i
don't know let's say i have 60
strawberries
now what is the ratio of apples to
oranges to strawberries so i could write
it like this i could write what is the
ratio
of all right like this apples
apples to oranges
to oranges
two strawberries
two
strawberries
well i could start off by literally
saying well for 60 strawberries for
every 60 strawberries for every 60
strawberries i have 40 oranges
i have 40 oranges and i have 20 apples
so this would be legitimate you could
say the ratio of apples to oranges to
strawberry
are 20 to
sorry 20 to 40 to 60 and that wouldn't
be wrong but we saw before we could put
into reduced form so think of what's the
largest number that divides into all
three of these we can't just do it into
two of these now because now my ratio
has three actual quantities
well the largest number that divides
into all of these guys is 20. so if we
divide all of them by 20 we can then say
for every
one apple
i now have if you divide this guy by 20
i have
two oranges
and i have
three strawberries so the ratio of
apples to oranges to strawberries is one
to two to three and i got that in every
case by just dividing these guys all by
20. i divided by 20. i think you get the
general idea if someone were to ask you
what's the ratio of let me just write it
down because it never hurts to have a
little bit more clarification if someone
wanted to know the ratio of strawberries
to
oranges let me get into my orange color
strawberries two oranges two apples
two apples i thought i was going to do
that in yellow two apples what is this
ratio going to be
well for every three strawberries
i have two oranges
two oranges and i have one apple so then
it would be three to two to one the
general idea is whatever order someone
asks you for the different items you put
the ratio is going to be in that same
exact order now in all of the examples
so far i gave you the number of quantity
the quantity of things we had and we
figured out the ratio what if it went
the other way
what if it went the other way
what if i told you a ratio what if i
said
the ratio
the ratio of boys to girls in a
classroom
boys to girls
is
let's say the ratio of boys to girls is
two to three which i could have also
written as two to three just like that
so for every two boys i have three girls
or for every three girls i have two boys
and let's say that there are
there are
students
in
the classroom
in the classroom
and then someone were to ask you how
many girls are there how many
girls
are in
in
the classroom
so this seems a little bit more
convoluted than what we did before we
know the total number of students we
know the ratio but how many girls are in
the room so let's think about it this
way the fact that the ratio of boys to
girls i'll write it like this
boys
maybe i'll be stereotypical with the
colors the ratio of boys to girls
is equal to
is equal to two
two two three i hate to be so
stereotypical but it doesn't hurt
two to three
the ratio of boys to girls is two to
three so this says for every three girls
there's two boys for every two boys
there's three girls but what does it
also say it also says
for every
for every five students
there
are
what there are two boys and three girls
there are
two boys
and
three girls
now why is this help this statement
helpful
well how many groups of five students do
i have
i have 40 students in my class right
there
right i have 40 students in my class
and for every five students there are
two boys and three girls so how many
groups of five students do i have
so i have total of 40 students
let me do it in this purple color i have
40 students
students
and then there are
five students per group five students
per group
and i figured out that group just by
looking at the ratio for every five
students i have two boys and three girls
so how many groups of five students do i
have
so that means that i have
eight groups
forty divided by five i have eight
groups
of five students
now we're wondering how many girls there
are so each group is going to have three
girls
each group has three girls so each
group
has
three
girls
each group has three girls so how many
girls do i have i have eight groups each
of them have three girls so i have eight
groups times three girls per group is
equal to 24 girls 24
girls in the classroom and you could do
the same exercise with boys how many
boys are there there's a couple of ways
you could do it you could say for all
for every group there are two boys
there's eight groups there's 16 boys or
you could say look there's 40 students
24 of them are girls 40 minus 24 is 16.
so either way you could get to 16 boys
and if you want to think of a kind of a
fast way to do it and it would be
identical you'd say look
two plus three is five so for every five
students two boys three girls how many
groups are there you say 40 divided by
five is equal to eight groups every
group has three girls so you do eight
times three is equal to
girls let's do one that's a little bit
harder than that a little bit harder
than that
let's do one where i say that the ratio
the ratio
of
let's say well let's let's go back to
let's go to the farm the farm example
the ratio of a sheep
i'll do sheep in white
the ratio of sheep
to
i don't know
chickens
to chickens
to
i don't know what's another farm animal
two pigs
the ratio of sheep to chicken
to pigs maybe i should just say chicken
right there the ratio of sheep to
chicken to pigs or chickens i should say
chickens
is let's say the ratio is
2 10. and notice i can't reduce this
anymore there's no number that divides
into all of these so this is the ratio
of sheep to chickens to pigs and let's
say that i have a total of 51 animals so
i have a total
of 51
animals
and i want to know how many chickens do
i have
how
many
chickens
how many chickens do i have
well we do the same idea for every two
sheep i have five chickens and i have 10
pigs that tells me for every 17 animals
so for every
17 animals
so every group of 17 animals what do i
have and where did i get 17 from i just
added 2 plus 5 plus 10. so for every 17
animals
i am going to have let me pick a new
color i'm going to have two sheep
two sheep five chickens
five chickens and ten pigs ten pigs
now how many groups of 17 animals do i
have i have a total of 51 animals
so if there's 17 animals per group 51
animals divided by 17 animals per group
i have three groups
of
17 animals three groups of 17 animals
now i wanna know how many chickens
every group has five chickens
every group has five chickens we already
know that and i have three groups so i
have three groups every group has five
chickens so i'm going to have three
times 5 chickens which is equal to
chickens
15 chickens
not too bad all i did is add these up
and say for every 17 animals i've got
five chickens i've got three groups of
17 so for each of those groups i have
five chickens three times five is 15
chickens and you could use the same
process to figure out the number of
sheep or pigs you might have